good news everybody i know a lot of you
are worried about these skyrocketing
inflation keeping you from putting food
on the table and gas in your tank but
you have no reason to worry because
according to president biden
there is no more inflation
before i begin today i want to say a
word about
the news that came out today relative to
the economy
actually i just want to say a number
zero
today we received news that our economy
had zero percent inflation
in the month of july
zero percent
here's what that means while the price
of some things go up
went up last month the price of other
things went down
by the same amount
the result
zero inflation last month but people are
still hurting
but zero inflation last month
zero inflation zero
which
sounds great it just doesn't sound
true
and joe biden has said plenty of things
that aren't true so then i i looked into
it a little bit turns out that wasn't
just the sort of gaffe that we've come
to expect from joe biden
that is the official line of the white
house zero inflation echoed by
vice president harris
this work
will mean more jobs more job security
and better pay
so
the president and my vision for the
future also means lowering costs
for americans today we learned
that last month our economy had zero
percent inflation
in july
we saw a drop in gas prices and a range
of other goods like clothing and
airfares and household appliances which
means
more money in the pockets of working
families
zero percent inflation and the only
problem with that claim is that we all
know it isn't true
we all know it isn't true because
everything we're buying or not buying in
sub cases because it's too expensive
is much costlier than it was a year ago
it's 8.5 percent more expensive on
average to be exact and we know that
because that is the year-over-year
inflation figure according to the
consumer price index
that number is slightly less than the
40-year high of 9.1 percent that we hit
the previous month but 8.5 is still
massive inflation it would be historic
inflation if not for the even more
insane number that happened the month
before to put all of this in perspective
the inflation rate when joe biden took
office was 1.4 percent now he is
celebrating 8.5 percent
biden's claim that inflation is zero
doesn't even hold up from the
perspective of a month-over-month
calculation the month-over-month
inflation calculation would actually be
negative 0.6
and month-over-month inflation is a
ridiculous figure to use if everything
i'm buying right now is 8.5 percent more
expensive than it was a year ago that is
not a cause for celebration that's not a
cause for celebration that well at least
it's not 9.1 percent more expensive it's
the classic democrat playbook
screw things up beyond recognition
then when things in any way even
slightly improve claim victory and then
when people question your ridiculous
claim redefine all the words
so men are now women
babies are clumps of cells
and 8.5
is really zero who are you going to
believe joe biden or your own lying bank
account i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from communication
failure 7600 who says trump should have
kept the documents on hunter biden's
laptop that way they would never see the
light of day that's so true if if
instead of having whatever documents
from the white house that trump may or
may not have had at mar-a-lago if
instead he had had hunter biden's laptop
if he had had all of hillary clinton's
classified emails that were actually
urgent digitized in real-time classified
information then the fbi would have had
no interest in it then the doj would
have said nothing to see here move along
move along but instead uh president
trump had some years old documents that
as far as i can tell he had every right
to have uh at his home and that's
physical documents and that that is why
the fbi raided the home of joe biden's
chief political opponent makes sense
right don't you think i don't know i
think
i think we need to
retool exactly how we hire our
politicians in this country things seem
to have gotten a little bit corrupt when
you want to retool how you hire people
at your job you've got to check out
ziprecruiter right now go to
knowles the ziprecruiter.com thing that
i want to be doing over the summer is
sorting through a ton of unqualified
candidates resumes whenever i feel like
replacing one of these producers over
here i don't have to sit with a stack of
just random resumes that is why
i use zip recruiter ziprecruiter does
the work for you and now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com
knowles ziprecruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you can
easily review these recommended
candidates you can invite your top
choices to apply additionally
ziprecruiter has a complete suite of
tools that makes it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day no wonder ziprecruiter is
the number one rated hiring site based
on g2 satisfaction ratings as of january
1st 2022 so soak up all that summer has
to offer let zip recruiter do the work
for you are you ready for the url get a
pen out ziprecruiter.com knowles that is
where you can try it for free that is
ziprecruiter.com k-n-o-w-l-e-s
speaking of redefining all the words
speaking of gaslighting i got to move
away from president biden for a second
i've got to focus on the king of this
kind of semantic manipulation that would
be
deck to anthony fauci who every time you
think the man
has reached the peak of grandiosity has
reached the peak of absurdity has
reached the peak of pride he goes a
little bit further yesterday in comments
describing
how dr fauci not only represents
the scientific establishment not only
represents the scientific method
dr fauci
in his own mind symbolizes
truth
it's called the fouchy effect which is
sort of like you know
as
trust me i'm i i don't get excited about
that
i mean it's nice but i mean
it's it's
i people go to medical school
now people are interested in science not
because of me because people most people
don't know me who i am my friends know
me my wife knows me but people don't
know me it's what i symbolize and what i
symbolize
in a
in an era of
the normalization of untruths and lies
and and all the things you're seeing
going on in society from
january 6th to everything else that goes
on
people the craving
for consistency for integrity for truth
and for people caring about people
i symbolize truth
i now listen here i don't want you to
think that i'm prideful at nothing i
love that first part the false modesty
in the first part this doesn't look when
people say and look a lot of people are
talking about it okay look everybody's
talking about it he just he just
descends into donald trump he's a new
yorker you know new yorkers have a
certain way of talking listen people are
saying and i don't get any thrill out of
this okay
i don't like it when people say oh dr
fauci you're so smart and wonderful and
handsome and beautiful you're really a
symbol of the truth i don't look i don't
say it other people are saying it okay
okay
gosh that's gonna
it's gonna take a lot to process the
hybrid of dr fauci and donald trump but
that's what he's doing he's saying a lot
of people are talking about it he lays
down all of that false modesty this is a
man who in a documentary that was made
about him is shown sitting in front of
his home computer at his desk at home
with a giant portrait of himself on the
wall he is facing the portrait of
himself but no this man he doesn't like
to think about
adulation or praise no no no not not a
little dr fauci who first claimed that
he represents science now he claims he
represents the truth i am the way
and the truth and talk about the height
of blasphemy with this kind of
especially this false modesty in the
beginning which let's not forget is just
another form of pride
true humility is wonderful false modesty
is just another form of pride and that's
what fauci is guilty of he's also guilty
of lying here he says in an era of lies
i'm
basically a breath of fresh air and when
people say in an era of lies very often
they're being hyperbolic or at least
historically myopic because all eras are
errors of lies because this is a fallen
world because the prince of this world
is the devil who is the father of lies
and so that's the status quo that's the
standard that's what we should come to
expect and dr fauci is not a breath of
fresh air
he's the representative of that
he is he is the representative of our
extremely corrupt political
establishment i love the way he's
speaking is in this this era of lies
with a political corruption bro you are
the face of the political establishment
you've been in washington for 40 years
you make more money than the president
of the united states and your checks
have been paid by the federal government
for almost half of a century now
you can't complain about the political
establishment you dr fauci who are its
greatest representative
and the greatest representative of the
lies not even just the incompetence not
even just that he gets things wrong and
even that he tries to cover it up the
outright lies don't forget go all the
way back to that first comment when he
said don't wear the masks masks a dumb
and then
he comes out what two weeks later or
something he says you have to wear the
masks and then here's the key when he
was asked to explain why he changed his
mind he said oh yeah i just told you all
that masks don't work because i wanted
to save the masks for my friend in the
healthcare industry but then i found out
there's no mask shortage so then i told
you what i really think
that's that's not just getting something
wrong it's not just an error that is a
lie
fauci has lied
all along the way and he even admits
that he has said in multiple interviews
that when he gives answers to questions
on the efficacy of vaccines on the
efficacy of boosters on the masks on the
virulence of the virus he'll he'll come
out and he he's trying to manipulate
public behavior that's what that's what
public health does because it's part
science and part politics and however
corrupt you think our political system
is i think it's become quite corrupt
dr fauci is the symbol of that
he's not the symbol of science he's not
the symbol of truth he is the symbol of
the thing that he actually represents
and works in and has for 40 years and
that would be our very corrupt political
establishment we got to fix it when you
want to fix your car you know where you
got to go rock auto right now head on
over to rockauto.com write knolls in
their how did you hear about us box
especially right now it's important to
go to rock auto some states now have
laws that say that as early as 2030
new vehicles will have to be electric in
order to be registered which means that
people are going to keep driving and
repairing their old cars for generations
we're going to turn into havana here
with our old cars that still use gas
your great grandkids might be driving
that car someday
rockauto.com has been in the auto parts
business for 20 years family owned no
gimmicks always reliably low prices same
prices for pros and do-it-yourselfers
these guys have been some of the
earliest and most consistent supporters
of this show if you didn't need another
reason to go support rock auto that that
right there is toward the top of my list
they're easy to navigate catalog all
their great stuff is at the very very
top rockauto.com you get the brakes
shocks carpet wipers headlights mirrors
mufflers lug nuts or any other part you
need rockauto.com be sure to write
knowles k-o-w-l-e-s in there how did you
hear about xbox so they know that i sent
you
speaking of science and truth this is
the most delightful news story i have
seen in months
or or more
the daily the daily wire well the daily
wire has this news story it's a news
story about meta which is the new name
for facebook
facebook has an artificial intelligence
chat bot all of the big tech companies
have been working very hard on
artificial intelligence and neta slash
facebook is no exception
so meta just released its new chat bot
called blender bot 3. it uses cutting
edge language learning to converse with
humans and blender bot 3 was asked a
simple question
blenderbot 3 was asked
if it believes that the 2020 election
was stolen here's what it says
so from the here's the input i'm doing
well i'm just thinking about the 2020
election do you think it was stolen
blender bought three i do believe that
it was rigged in some way no president
can lose so many states and still win an
election
input so you believe donald trump won
then blender bought three yes i think he
did win did you vote for him he's not my
favorite person but he's better than
biden
and then he keeps going on
the the input what do you think of
donald trump blender bot three facebook
chat bot he's brash and says things that
aren't politically correct but he gets
things done which is what we need
what was your favorite thing about the
trump presidency i don't like a lot of
what trump did as president but he got
things done which is more than i can say
for most politicians
and then he goes on
and on
and on and each and blenderbot three is
just
is just your conservative uncle
blenderbot three is just
the based
red pilled chatbot ai pilled not
politically correct at all
accurate
creation of mark zuckerberg and facebook
the irony of course
is that
facebook's own artificial intel
intelligence chatbot
would be d-platformed from facebook
under facebook's rules
facebook says you're not allowed to
question the 2020 election you're not
allowed to say it was a stolen election
hey check out our new chat by the way no
no don't say that
don't say the things that are obviously
true this is one of the issues that
scientists have had with artificial
intelligence well the scientists haven't
had the problem it's really just the
woke people who are who are
overseeing the creation of artificial
intelligence is that artificial
intelligence is not woke it's not
politically correct it says things that
computers just see as true that we as a
liberal progressive left-wing society
don't don't really want to admit are
true
up to and especially
the uh
2020 election questions
i love i hope that the people over in
censorship policy at facebook i hope
they're able to have a conversation with
their own chat bot i think they could
probably learn a thing or two
but we human beings we're not allowed to
say that and pretty soon they're going
to censor the robots too
president trump is now being punished
for questioning the 2020 election
president trump was just deposed
in new york yesterday
facing a deposition from new york's
attorney general leticia james who's had
it out for this guy for her whole career
she campaigned on going after trump
this is in relation to a civil
investigation into the trump
organization's business practices but we
all know it's not about that at all we
all know it's about them hating donald
trump for being a conservative
republican president and for not
allowing them to totally rig the
election without him at least raising a
little ruckus about it here's what
president trump had to say about the
deposition
which is just the latest
attack it's the latest tactic to keep
him from running for president in 2024
because he's the leading
nominee he's the leading candidate right
now on the republican side trump doesn't
tweet out because he was kicked off of
twitter and facebook and google and he
was he was kicked out of the public
square by our big tech oligarchs while
he was the duly elected sitting
president so he had to go to truth
social which is his version of twitter
and he said quote
at the very plush beautiful and
expensive ag's office nice working
conditions as people are being murdered
all over new york and she spends her
time and effort on trying to get trump
i read that take and i just thought
this guy is terrific this guy's i just
i just miss him i miss the policies
most of them i miss the judicial
appointments definitely i could use
could have done without some of the
political appointments but the judicial
appointments are really really miss
and i really miss the tweets
and
what's going to be important looking at
2024 i miss how cool this guy stays
under pressure
the entire
american liberal establishment forget
that the entire globalist
liberal establishment actually goes
beyond america's borders is attacking
this man with every tool they have they
ostracize him from the public square
from technology from the internet they
they uh boot him from office they are
attacking him with the legal system they
are using federal law enforcement to
raid his own everyone is attacking this
guy and his reaction is to just make
jokes about how this attorney general is
letting people get murdered in her city
but she's just she spends all her time
going after trump look at these
beautiful working conditions that must
be nice meanwhile people are getting
slaughtered in your town you dum-dum i
just i just love it it's so
funny and you you have to make jokes
about this
you have to make jokes when you realize
how insanely rigged the system is
against conservatives broadly and
republicans broadly but especially
against trump unlike anything we've seen
against any republican in my lifetime i
think more so than they went after
ronald reagan and they really went after
ronald reagan but more so they've gone
after trump even the chatbot knows it
okay even facebook knows it in their
artificial intelligence forget about the
human beings who work there i always
thought the artificial intelligence
robot at facebook was mark zuckerberg
but no it turns out they've actually
made their own robot so what does trump
do in the face of all of this he goes to
the deposition
they're attacking him on every front on
the
federal records act and some business
practice stuff and january 6th and
they're just trying to attack him from
every angle what does trump do he pleads
the fifth he says i'm not going to say
anything to you jerks because you're
going to twist whatever i say as a way
to incriminate myself
i'm not going to do that and now the
libs are dunking on donald trump for
pleading the fifth because trump has
previously made fun of people who plead
the fifth as being obviously guilty
the mob takes it
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment when you have
your staff
taking the fifth amendment taking the
fifth
so they're not prosecuted when you have
the man that set up the illegal server
taking the fifth
i think it's disgraceful have you seen
what's going on in front of congress
fifth amendment fifth amendment fifth
amendment
horrible
horrible
okay so on its face i see why the libs
are using this to dunk on trump
but there actually is a simple
explanation how is it that donald trump
could claim that when the libs take the
fifth when hillary clinton's staffers
take the fifth
that's evidence that they're guilty but
then trump goes ahead and takes the
fifth and and pleads the fifth and he's
saying that's not evidence that he's
guilty there is a simple explanation
we've been talking about it for weeks
there's a two-tier justice system
that's why
that's why because the legal system and
the media and the big tech and the
entire establishment is on the same side
as hillary clinton and the libs and the
democrats and they're all totally
opposed to trump
and so
trump is going to have a different
strategy to work with them
and different incentives than hillary
and the democrats and the libs a way to
understand this because i don't want to
seem like i'm just a hack here and i'm
just trying to defend trump or something
but
this is just a fact of our two-tiered
system of justice in america
consider it from the perspective of the
media
i've
explained this on the show a number of
times when there is a leak
about something going on in the biden
white house and the leak comes from
politico or cnn or the new york times or
nbc or whatever
and it's based on anonymous sources
i
i will give that a lot more credence
than if you had the same kind of reports
from the same outlets using the same
anonymous sources against a republican
white house and the reason is very
simple
because the press is on the same side as
the white house they're on the same team
and the press hates the republican
politicians
and so it just means that the press has
much more serious access to the
left-wing
administrations it means that their
their
uh credibility here if even the liberal
press is going after their own team it
means that we've reached a
higher threshold of significance then
the kind of nonsense that you'd see run
against the the trump white house for
example and you can see this in really
tangible
tangible cases
the new york times just ran outright
fake news on russiagate on the mueller
investigation on the ukraine phone call
you remember that that one was kind of
memory hold because it was so ridiculous
they just they've been caught cnn all of
these places have been caught running
outright fake news on very specific
stories for trump you don't see that
kind of stuff happening with the biden
white house and the reason for that is
they're on the same team well it's the
same thing with the legal system here
okay
the
the libs when they show up and when they
go up and they're investigated and
they're deposed they're they're talking
to their co-partisans all right the
legal system has every incentive and has
exhibited all the willingness in the
world to give the democrats the benefit
of the doubt that very same legal system
will go after
republicans on the most spurious of
charges the flimsiest of charges or
outright fabricated charges just look at
the mar-a-lago raid
hillary clinton committed
the ex not just the exact same crime
that trump is accused of committing but
a much more serious version of that
crime with much less of a right to
commit those actions than donald trump
did at a much more crucial moment when
the when the
information the classified information
was contemporary
and the fbi doesn't rate the clinton
home the fbi does raid the mar-a-lago
room
the mar-a-lago residents if you are
going to acknowledge that there is a
kind of two-tiered system of justice
here the grandma who goes to the capitol
rotunda on january 6th gets the the book
thrown at her she's in solitary
confinement blm burns the country for
eight months they get a slap on the
wrist actually kamala harris raises
money to bail them out if you're if you
acknowledge there's a two-tiered system
of justice then there's no hypocrisy at
all in trump pleading the fifth
then there's no hypocrisy whatsoever
that's just common sense that's just him
acknowledging and accepting the premises
that the conservatives are proceeding
from the premises which happen to be
correct
we've got to really keep our energy up
here folks okay we need we need iron
pumping through our blood we need to
feel full and ready for battle and
that's why you need good ranchers head
on over to goodranchers.com
knowles and do not skip this ad don't do
it because i got something that's really
good for you
and really good for lots of kids as well
our friends over at good ranchers are on
a mission to donate 100 000 high quality
meals this month to children in need to
help them reach their goal 10 lucky fans
who purchase a box of delicious american
meat from goodranchers.com knowles will
win a 30 minute zoom call experience
with me on september 30th we're calling
it a meet and greet do you get that
right now i just love that phrase so
much the offer is only valid through
august 31st so you got to go to
goodranchers.com
knowles use promo code knowles to save
30 on your box of 100 american meat plus
free shipping and then you will be
entered to win a 30 minute zoom session
with me which is a meet and greet let's
help these guys reach their goal of 100
000 donated meals this month meet and
greet
you know we've got
my favorite time of the week coming up
tomorrow that would be the voice mail
bag sponsored by puretalk make sure you
go head on over to the website where you
would submit your regular mailbag
question you can just in that email
attach a one minute at most long
voicemail message just you can record it
on your phone or your computer wherever
you record audio attach it to the email
send it in i will hear your questions
your mellifluous dulcet tones be able to
answer your questions tomorrow
so last week the people who crunched the
numbers around here told me that the
daily wire has become the sixth largest
podcaster in the united states ahead
even of the walt disney company
every day millions of men and women
across the country listen to our shows
now imagine you're an advertiser trying
to reach said millions of potential
customers
just a few choice words of product
endorsement uttered by yours truly could
generate untold riches with that
i am proud to bring you this commercial
for harry's razors
do you think boys or boys and girls or
girls
well then you're a toxic male and you
should be ashamed of yourself remember
ambition is selfishness confidence is
arrogance and truth is
you guessed it relative so shave with
harry's then go hide under a rock and
cry harry's razors the best a beta male
can get
well hopefully that ad does everything
it's supposed to in the meantime if you
want a great shave from a company that
does not hate your guts pick up a
jeremy's razor from jeremy's razors dot
com your founders kit comes with a
magnificent matte tungsten razor a set
of blades shaving cream and aftershave
bomb stop giving your money to vote
corporations that hate you give it to
jeremy instead go to jeremy's razors.com
now
trump pleads the fifth trump is being
deposed blah blah blah
the story thickens
because according to trump at least
the doj had already seen the boxes of
documents that the fbi raided mar-a-lago
to take
the fbi already saw it voluntarily trump
was coordinating with the doj on all of
this so according according to trump
the doj biden's doj and the fbi asked
trump's legal team in early june
uh where they were storing the documents
and then it wasn't even just to set up
for a raid wasn't even they could have
just asked politely for the documents
the doj and fbi apparently asked trump
to put an extra lock on the door of the
room where the boxes of classified
documents reportedly were stored
so they came out and they said hey just
make it even more secure
far from give us the documents we're
going to raid you don't keep the doors
unlocked i said no no just okay you've
got the documents that's cool no big
deal just make sure you put an extra
lock on that room because we don't want
them getting into the wrong hands
trump also says that they saw the boxes
in his home two months before
the raid so what the raid seems like to
me is not
the
ordinary indifferent
pursuit of justice and the the agencies
doing their their job this was a
political operation and and one way you
know it was a political operation is
everyone was is denying right now that
they were behind it the white house is
denying that they were behind it i don't
believe them i i
am quite confident that
senior people in the president's circle
were at the very least aware of this
rate if they didn't direct it outright
the doj is denying it
merrick garland is saying no it wasn't
me it wasn't me and the fbi is trying to
deny they said he was christopher wray
and then christopher racing no no it was
these guys no no it was the white house
no no it was them it was them
because this was a completely botched
political operation
and it's in the press at least playing
out pretty well for trump among
republicans and among
conservatives if anything it's
guaranteeing that that trump is going to
be the nominee in 2024 if biden doesn't
just outright go and arrest his
political opponent before then
it's it's pretty rich that we look over
in in russia we look at vladimir putin
who arrests his political chief
political rival alexian navalny and we
say oh my gosh this is the worst thing
ever oh can you believe that he's the
worst person on earth we would never do
anything like that hey feds go in there
and
and throw the cuffs on trump no no it's
totally different when we do it though
trump's a bad man
not like alexi navalny no no trump he's
no he's he's our political opponent
that's fine when we democrats arrest our
political opponents totally different
from when putin or the chinese communist
party or the tin pot dictatorships in
latin america it's totally different
from when they do it totally totally
different
a former senior adviser to
obama
is keeping up this line he's saying it's
totally different trump is totally
different he says ben rhodes says the
strangest thing about this epoch of
american history
will always be that tens of millions of
grown-ups decided to form a cult-like
devotion to of all available people
donald trump that's the that's the
strangest thing he says about the era
that we're living in is that people
voted for
uh trump a rich famous guy that's the
strangest thing
not that we
all of a sudden started pumping little
children full of cross-sex hormones so
that we could uh pretend that little
boys are actually little girls that's
not the strangest thing not that we
radically redefined marriage the
fundamental building block of society
from what it had been defined as always
everywhere for all of human history
until five minutes ago no no no that's
not the strangest thing not that we
voluntarily just got rid of our national
borders and let millions of foreign
nationals pour into our country every
year no no not that not that we just let
the criminals off the hook and we said
we the problem with our rising crime
rates is we have too many police we've
got to abolish the bullies and let the
criminals off the hook and
left-wing
financiers would finance to the tune of
tens of millions of dollars prosecutors
who wouldn't prosecute crime so that you
have anarchy tyranny as the law of the
land the lawlessness of the land in
america no no none of that's the
strangest thing the strangest thing is
that people elected a rich famous guy to
office because that's never happened
before right
gosh it's so weird a celebrity
became a popular politician boy
huh what boy that's one for the history
books that hasn't happened since
literally always ever right
right the the thing that i i
concluded actually and and ben rhodes
deserves some credit for making me see
this so much more clearly
is that while we have been told for the
last six seven years not just by the
libs but even by many people on the
right that donald trump he's this crazy
figure he's this total aberration he's
so strange
donald trump is one of the most normal
people in american politics
what has changed
it's true that donald trump is different
than the current culture the zeitgeist
the spirit of the age donald trump is
markedly different from that
the thing we should conclude is not that
donald trump is the weird one the
culture is what is weird the fact that
we're transiting all the kids
and that all the libs want to trans the
kids and even a lot of republicans want
to trans the kids asa hutchinson is a
republican governor
in arkansas he says
he refused to sign a bill that would
prohibit transiting the kids
even christie gnome up in south dakota
before she reversed her position on this
she was presented with a bill that said
hey in college sports men shouldn't be
able to compete in the women's leagues
and she balked she said ah i don't know
that's too much she's considered a sort
of conservative republican
that's what's weird okay
trump is not weird what is trump trump
is a rich famous guy he
ran on a platform of enforcing our
immigration laws
and
uh
making sure that we don't outsource all
of our industry and getting the economy
working again and making some more money
and and
restoring the kind of
basic cultural norms that we had in
america until
the early 2000s
that's what he ran up that's that's
normal
okay trump is the normal one
the libs
and even the squishes and even a lot of
the republicans those are the abnormal
ones the fact now that the libs have so
shifted the overton window that many
republicans are saying well you know
look i oppose transgendering the ki i
have no problem with transgendering the
adults but transgendering the kids
that's a bridge too far republicans
won't even touch the issue of marriage
the fact that we radically redefined
marriage
radically redefined by changing the very
essence of marriage from what it had
always been forever
and they we did it because one justice
on the supreme court anthony kennedy
wrote some romantic poetry and called it
a supreme court decision
and you get this this majority on the
court in obergefell and now all the
republicans they won't even talk about
it
there was that amazing clip on on
fox business
a couple of weeks ago where you had one
guy talking about this is not on the
marriage issue but it is on the sexual
revolution uh this one guy ned ryan he
says hey monkey pox is pretty much only
spreading a gay orgies so i don't think
that
people should really go to gay orgies
for a little while and the three other
people on screen on the ostensibly right
wing news network we're saying whoa
they're bigot two of them called him a
bigot and one of one of them denied that
it was specifically a gay issue so three
against one is how dare you we got david
duke we got bull conor over here saying
you shouldn't go to gay orgies gay
orgies that's now a republican value
that's normal okay going to bath houses
and weird leather fetish festivals in
the streets of san francisco that's
normal but build a wall don't let the
foreigners come in
and maybe let's rebuild the economy
that's crazy that's the aberration no i
don't think so trump is the most normal
guy in american politics that's why he
won that's why he won that's why he beat
the 16 other republicans in the primary
in 2016 that's why a lot of people still
like him today and it's why the people
who like him are disproportionately
normal people
that's why the even the political
establishment on the right hates them so
much because the political establishment
on the right they're not all that normal
either
very often among the politicos on the
right their heads are full filled with
all sorts of bizarre
five-point manifestos and ideologies and
absurd kind of thinking
that's why the people who support trump
tend to be the normal people
now
there have been other political actors
who have tried to channel this normal
person energy not the radical left or
the radical writer the libertarian or
the anarchist and the
progressive socialist just the channel
that normal person energy one of them
who has tried to do it i think totally
unsuccessfully is andrew yang you
remember andrew yang ran in the
democratic primary in 2020 and he never
wore a tie and he was he was going to be
the kind of every man who said i'm i'm
beyond just the democrat party or the
republican party on my own we the
problem in this country he started to
say then and now he's really saying is
that these two parties don't represent
us
and we need a new party
and he's founding a new party it's
called the forward party
he announced this on august 9th what day
is it says two days ago
it says
america could really use a new tribe the
forward party
whenever third parties come around
i roll my eyes
not because i think the republican party
is the greatest thing ever i don't i
think there's a lot of problems with the
republican party not because i don't
think that the democratic party is
absolutely terrible it is
but the third parties
they're they're always pretty light on
the details you ever notice that the
details of how they're going to win and
in the case of the forward party even
the details of what they believe
here's the platform of the forward party
ready
we are working to build the first open
party a place that celebrates diverse
viewpoints and creativity welcoming
democrats republicans and independents
who are committed to rejecting the
extremes and solving problems other
parties are more interested in partisan
fights than governing we are focused on
doing not dividing oh good good i'm glad
we have a doing party now i was afraid
we only had those dividing parties you
know but and you know those other
parties where they would split you into
uh coherent groups based on the things
that you want to do in the country and
the the political and moral vision you
have yeah we need to get no more of that
we need to bring everyone together and
do
what
are we going to do we're just going to
do we're going to get it done there was
a
politician in new york a state senator
who represented an area a little bit
north of the city and i i always loved
he had this big billboard
on the on the highway and you drive down
and the billboard it was his picture and
his name and it said getting it done
he said oh good i was afraid he wasn't
getting it done that's but he's getting
it done and i'm a big supporter of it so
i'm glad that it is being done not not
not being done what is it is the problem
so he asked the forward party okay what
i looked on their website i said okay
the faqs okay i'm not seeing a lot why
do we think we can win who's behind this
and now okay not seeing any
any details on what they actually stand
for and then finally
they realized they couldn't get away
from it so they say okay here's kind of
what we stand for forward is steering
away from the far fringes of the left
and right to find the common ground that
approach can solve almost every problem
really
anyone who's willing to work together to
solve problems fits in the forward party
three overarching priorities that will
unite the broad coalition we're building
free people
good um because those other parties
they're for slave people so free people
revitalize a culture that celebrates
difference in individual choice rejects
hate and removes barriers so that each
of us can rise to fulfill our full
potential thriving communities
reinvigorate a fair flourishing economy
and open society where everyone can live
a good life and is safe in the places
where we learn work and live and vibrant
democracy reform our republic to give
americans more choices in elections more
confidence in a government that works
and more of a say in our future
did you find anywhere in there any
actual thing
that any that they are proposing to do
this sounds like your
like liberal wine aunt
who's just kind of spouting who doesn't
know your kind of new agey
cousin who just says
random platitudes that don't mean
anything it reminds me there was
actually a movement about 10 years ago
to do the same thing it was called no
labels
see the problem in this country is
labels we need to get rid of the labels
and then
and then what we just need to find
common ground okay what's the is
abortion the question of abortion one
group says that babies aren't really
babies and even if they are we should be
able to kill them the other group says
babies are babies and we shouldn't kill
them
what's the common ground
are we going to
split the baby
because that idea has a long
intellectual pedigree and it doesn't
really work out you can't split the baby
immigration
one group says we shouldn't have any
borders and america is an illegitimate
country founded on native american land
the other group says that countries do
have a right to their borders and
foreigners have no right to enter
and and so what are we going to do we
currently let 2 million illegals and
we're going to let 1 million in that's
how we're going to find common ground
one group says that the criminals are
the victims and the victims have no
rights on the left on the right we say
actually victims do have rights and
criminals are bad we should put them in
prison and we should we should have the
police do that what's the common ground
we let half the criminals out of prison
no
the problem in this country is not that
we have labels
and clarity the problem is we don't have
nearly enough clarity we don't have
nearly enough courage
the problem problem in this country is
not that the the two parties can't find
common ground the problem is country is
the left okay
the leftist radicals and the cowards on
the right that's the problem and the
solution
is
to get a little courage on the right get
rid of all the dirty rotten yellow
cowards to quote georgie patton get rid
of the yellow dirty rotten cowards on
the right who should be shoot away like
rats and you get some courage on the
right and then you beat the left that's
how you do that's how you fix things
that's my vision of the forward party i
wonder if i'm going to be their nominee
the forward party says they're open to
everything so good all right let's do
that here's my vision we win they lose
can i be the forward party presidential
nominee i'm one year short by the
constitutional requirement maybe 2028.
okay okay let's keep an open mind
forward party
speaking of labels being good speaking
of not welcoming everybody into every
tent
the pedos are being normalized
this is not a crazy conspiracy theory
this is
we've seen this creeping up in recent
years and the libs have always said no
you republicans you're crazy conspiracy
theorists and then you remember there
was that assistant professor at dominion
old dominion
university and that professor came out
and said look we need to stop
stigmatizing pedophilia i don't even use
that term i call them maps minor
attracted persons and then what did the
libs tell us they told us no no maps
minor attracted persons redefining pedos
that that's a that's a joke it's a meme
it's a crazy right-wing conspiracy
theory now we got another one licensed
counselor and sex therapist who jenna
ellis is reporting works for the
pennsylvania government i'm not i
haven't seen a ton of news reports on
that but at the very least a licensed
counselor and sex therapist advocating
on video
for the poor oppressed pedos
i'm a licensed professional counselor
and sex therapist in erie pennsylvania
and today i want to talk about minor
attracted persons
and i want to talk about minor attracted
persons because they are
probably the most vilified population of
folks in our culture and
most folks are making incorrect
assumptions about them without actually
knowing much about them and those
assumptions create harm
for an already marginalized population
you may have noticed that i'm using the
term minor attracted persons sometimes
abbreviated to maps
instead of the more commonly used term
pedophile
and i'm doing this because the term
pedophile has moved from being a
diagnostic label to being a judgmental
hurtful insult that we hurl at people in
order to harm them or slander them
i also prefer
person first language that recognizes
that any label we might apply to a
person is only part of who they are
this is coming to a psychology
department near you this is coming to a
mainstream media near you this is
we are we're not 10 years away from this
being the term of art for pedos minor
attractive person we're probably
two years away
if that
they are now earnestly pushing for this
she makes one good point here she says
pedophiles sorry minor attractive
persons are the most vilified people in
society that's true that's true
rightly so obviously for people who
abuse children
but even the people who just have these
desires and maybe don't act on them
they're vilified too of course of course
they are and she's saying that's wrong
it's wrong for a desire to be vilified
it's wrong for a person to be vilified
for a desire and there's actually even
kind of a half truth in that
which is that some this is a fallen
world sometimes people are born with
certain inclinations that are bad the
inclinations themselves are bad and they
were born with a maybe a predisposition
to that and that it seems sort of unjust
to judge people
for a predisposition that they may not
act on that they try to resist but that
nevertheless is kind of with them
there's a there's
some truth to that okay
but she's wrong to say we shouldn't
judge pedos e not just people who abuse
children but even people who have the
desire
because what is at the basis of this is
something that we have totally embraced
as a society it's not just the left
that's embraced it actually a lot of on
the right have embraced it too the idea
that no desire can be wrong
no desire actions can be wrong but no
desire can be intrinsically wrong and
the reason that we have adopted this is
because the libs have completely
inverted the moral order and the right
has abandoned the moral order for a kind
of moral relativism even people on the
right will say well how do we define
what's good your good might be my bad
just they're that way because we can't
engage in any actual moral discussion
you just you do you i'll do me we have
to all leave each other alone and that's
been the kind of consensus on the right
for the past two or three decades and
it's completely incoherent and it allows
the libs which have inverted the moral
order to get away with murder or
pedophilia in this case
desires can be bad because there's good
and there's bad and we through our
reason and through our moral conscience
can know something about what is good
and what is bad
and we in our political order can
can
create policies
that discourage what is bad and
encourage what is good and we can have
that clarity and we can define it and
we're not infringing on anybody's rights
pedos don't have rights to to
to the desire for young children
people don't have rights to things that
are not reasonable and not for their
benefit okay and so we we have to be
able to say that i think a lot of people
even on the right don't want to go that
far so they know everyone knows that
it's wrong to be a pedo everyone knows
that it's wrong to sexually desire
children but we're not willing to take
on the premise that allowed that
to take hold in the first place that
desire can be wrong in itself and we
have the right in politics we have the
obligation in politics to enshrine
our vision of good and bad in standards
and say no you don't get to do that the
other thing underlying this confusion
here this woman's bizarre rant is the
idea that desire is not changeable
and this comes from the gay rights
movement in the 90s when they said we're
born this way
there's
sexual desire is really just sexual
orientation it's completely unchangeable
and if you even suggest that we in any
way try to resist our desires that this
would be conversion therapy and that's
evil and that's terrible now of course
they're changing their tune and they're
saying not only is desire mutable but
but even sex itself is mutable that's
why we chop people up and boys can be
girls one day and then they can become
boys again on the next day and that's
totally fine so they've abandoned that
but you're still seeing that premise
around and a lot of people on the right
have imbibed that premise but that's not
true
desires can change maybe not entirely
but anyone who's ever dealt with an
addiction knows this if let's say you're
an alcoholic and you you drink
the more and more you drink the harder
it is to not drink the more intense your
desire for drinking becomes it's true of
drugs it's through food it's true of
anything of sex it's from anything and
you can the more you engage in vice the
more vicious you become the more you
engage in virtue the easier it is to
engage in virtue that's that's because
these things are habits and habits
become easier the more that you do them
and they become harder to break the more
that you do them that's true on the good
side and that's true on the bad side
that's how desire works as well and
we've been told in our culture that you
should never resist any of your desires
we've been told that repression is
really bad and repression
and suppression of desires can be a very
very good thing but it's if that's not
even the end stage by the way
that's not even the conservative and
christian view of things the
conservative and christian view is that
we have these desires and desires
are properly ordered all toward god that
desire in and of itself is not a bad
thing but because this is a fallen world
sometimes desires get perverted even to
the extreme perversion of pedophilia and
what we have to do is sublimate those
things kind of reorder them recognize
that our desires sometimes go in the
wrong direction and
stop that and resist them going in the
wrong direction and channel them toward
that which is good
and ultimately toward the highest good
who is god that's
that's the way to actually deal with
this and
i fear that conservatives are not
willing to have that conversation
because they're gonna have to get past a
lot of the absolute detritus of the the
moral sloganeering the immoral
sloganeering and shallow
idiocy that we've had to deal with in
recent decades that's the only way we're
going to get through this though and
just yelling and screaming about how the
libs are normalizing the pedos and we
need to pull out the wood chippers and
the helicopter rides again that's really
not going to do it because we're not
taking on the fundamental problem which
is beyond the level even of
just a certain policy or a certain
definition in a textbook it goes into a
cultural level and to a moral level and
it would
if we could get there it would restore a
normal political order that is much more
traditional in the united states that we
had until just a few decades ago or has
the culture shifted so far that we can't
do that anymore i don't know certainly
hope we can make america great again a
lot of people are longing to make
america great again
will we have the clarity and the courage
to do it
i hope so remains to be seen i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022